- My mom's, like, incredible.
- She's very, very brave.
I hope she knows that she's very brave.
(bright music)
- The bravest thing that my mother ever did
was go to law school at 44 years old
after being out of the workforce for 20 some-odd years
and being a stay-at-home mom for just as long.
She was an aspiring journalist,
and she ended up getting married
and having kids young, and then raised her kids.
She woke up one morning, as she proclaims,
and just felt like all of a sudden
she had no responsibilities, her children were grown,
and so she took the LSAT, passing
and going to law school and passing the bar
and is now a full-time lawyer.
It's just taught me that the sky's the limit
and it's never too late if you want to
make a change in your life.
My mom's, like, incredible.
My dad died when I was younger,
and my mom just stepped up.
It's hard to raise kids as a single parent.
I have a disability, I have Tourette's Syndrome,
and it's harder when you're raising a kid with Tourette's.
I'm a comic, and my mother goes head to head with me.
She's also the funniest person I've ever met.
- My mom is a total queen.
She's a judge.
Just having that role model to look up to
throughout my life was really awesome.
I would stop by her courtroom.
One case, my mom addresses the defendant,
and she pulls her glasses down to the tip of her nose.
"If you think that speaking to someone
in that manner is appropriate, you will end up
right back in this courtroom,
and I will make sure it is in front of me."
And like...
Very queen.
- My mom had my brother when she was 18
and had me at 21, so she was fairly young.
We grew up on the border between
Tijuana and San Diego, living undocumented.
My mom had been only in the U.S.
for maybe four or five years, had been going
to English classes, and she came into my
second-grade classroom and surprised me by participating
in one of the monthly readings for their child.
I was super-excited to see my mom there.
Her voice was shaking.
She had a very thick accent.
I remember disregarding all of that
and being full of joy that my mom
was joining me in the classroom.
I don't think I ever thanked my mom enough for that moment,
for all that vulnerability, for braving through
what might have been maybe an embarrassing moment.
- There is a specific moment that stands out for me.
It was when I was in third grade.
My dad, he got promoted.
That entailed us having to move.
It was the end of the world for me.
I'm like, I have to leave my friends,
the Spice Girls album had just come out.
So it was a huge transition.
For my mom, at the time she was working
as a financial aid counselor at Federal State University.
I knew how much she loved that job.
Us moving to this new city also means
that you're having to really just change your whole life.
So leaving my family, we're leaving friends.
During that time of her trying to figure out
what am I going to do, applying for
job after job after job, I remember
some moments where it seemed like,
mom seems upset, but I remember her
just staying strong with her faith
and always being very hopeful.
After applying for a lot of positions
and going through applications and going to interviews,
she eventually got a position working
at the school that I attended.
She just in that moment taught me a lot
about not ever doubting yourself.
- I don't think she knows how brave she is.
She...
Hoo, um...
Yeah, well, 'cause I'm...
I'm one of seven,
and, uh, geez, sorry.
Ooh.
My dad passed away in 2006.
The fact that she's carried on with
the amount of strength and care
and unconditional love and support for each of us
is huge.
So I hope she knows that she's very brave.
She's very, very brave.
- Personally and professionally, you can do it.
If it's something that's going to
make you happy, to pursue it.
I know people that have run into her
in court and say she's really damn good at her job.
- Putting me above herself and making sure that
I felt included in that parent family tradition
that was happening in the classroom.
- The way that she can go from work
and would come home and cook dinner for us,
show up to all of my volleyball games,
I don't think that I always appreciated it,
but Mom, I love you so much.
Thank you for being a total queen and a role model for me.
- As long as you just trust the situation,
trust yourself, and hold onto your faith,
you can power through, really, anything.
- I love you, Mom, happy Mother's Day.
- Feliz dia de las madres, te amo, Mami.
- Happy Mother's Day, Mom.
I love you, and I know that you hate the beard,
but I will shave it off just for you.